how big is that thing it was the largest
trunk that ever existed a living fossil
thought to have been extinct over two
million years wrong who is scarier to go
up against the Meg or the rock yeah I'd
have to say to Meg the rocks a little
older he's got a slappable face whereas
the mick doesn't I didn't say
my good
it's Megalodon he's kidding right
who do you guys think is scarier to go
up against Jason or the Meg the Meg why
is that I mean it's the Megalodon I mean
Jason is you know how cool but this is a
creature that is so enormous and it's so
terrifying that there's no way that I
would ever be I think Jason is a bigger
apex predator I would be terrified of
Jason if you had to be in the water with
one of the two I don't know I don't know
it's a toss-up for me why Jason is
terrifying
he threatens my masculinity no it's not
scary he's like you know such a warm guy
you know the first time I met him I
thought as a leading actor they would
the production will you know give us a
visual name officially introduced for us
this is who this is hope and know we
have no chance to meet each other we
just met by natural one day I need to
work on set and I went to you know the
bathroom and he was not he didn't need
to work that day but he need to do
something about his costume we just met
bumping each other and I know him he
knows me and we said hi he said hi how
they say honey that was so you know
weird and all his image in my mind is so
cool never smile and very cool guy and
very you know tough guy I said that he
smelled oh it for me is like ah he has
such a nice teeth yes
[Music]
he looks heroic it's kind of got a
negative attitude Jason
so you obviously have a shirtless scene
in this movie what's more challenging
for you shirtless scenes are crying
scenes uh I don't like either of those
ah Donny oh yeah there's something that
pulls like a lot ago she how many times
have you seen him cry in a movie I feel
like once yes and how many times have
you seen him shirtless probably more
than once
yeah in a movie we're not doing any of
that you you were the last person
[Music]
everyone's freaking out that the dog in
this movie is going to die what do you
have to say to those people John's very
sorry for the for the pain he's caused
it happens I don't you know you should
see and then I yeah it's already very so
I will say it is fascinating cuz you
know people oh my god this dog there's
thousands of people in the water and
we're just eating popcorn one dog goes
in and everyone's panicking it's
terrible
[Music]
she won this you ugly what is the best
way to survive a shark attack I don't
think you can survive a lot it wants it
it tell other sharks take a bite and
they realize that they're not what
they're looking for
you know there it's an investigates
resource snap you know munch and a lot
of people plead out rather than get
eaten alive
ya know many people get you really know
they don't go back for the second choice
you know it's not oh this is tasty and
we're gonna you know eat these you know
it it's more about people sort of suffer
a wound and bleed out in the ocean what
is the best way to survive a shark
attack um you know I eyed alpha male the
shark you know I think just look him in
the eyes and be like no no and the shark
would be like that's like if it's bursts
from like funding me more like a diverse
no no no things have death need to find
it killing
but you just put a tracker on it you
guys ever watched Shark Week
you
[Music]